Hey Thoughty2 here.
There are some wild conspiracy theories out
there, lets delve into some of the most recently
concocted theories.
One of the most prolific conspiracies of recent
years is the disappearance of Malaysia Airlines
Boeing 777 flight MH370 on the 8th March 2014.
Theories range from alien abduction to a terrorist
hijacking.
But one of the most disturbing conspiracies
surrounding the plane's disappearance arose,
when it was discovered that an identical plane
to Malaysian Airlines flight MH370 was found
in storage at Tel Aviv's Ben Gurion Airport
in Israel.
The twin plane has been in storage at Tel
Aviv airport since November, 2013.
The only difference between this plane and
the one that disappeared over the Indian ocean
is the serial number.
So why do Israel have this identical plane
in storage and what are they planning to do
with it?
Conspiracy theorists believe Israel are planning
a false flag terror attack on the United States
similar to 9/11, where the plane will be filled
with explosives and flown into Manhattan.
There are also theories that Iran are involved
in this planned attack against the US.
Conspiracy theorists believe the real Malaysian
Airlines flight was hijacked and flown to
Iran where it was hidden from public view
in preparation for a terror attack.
This theory is backed up by the fact that
two Iranian men boarded the missing MH370
flight using stolen passports.
Could they have hijacked the plane?
But this isn't the only popular theory, others
include involvement from the Illuminati, North
Korea and even Edward Snowden.
It could be pure coincidence but a Reddit
user pointed out the missing Malaysian plane
was the 404th Boeing 777 to have ever been
built and we all know where we've seen that
number before.
Another conspiracy of modern times is that
Barack Obama is trying to bankrupt America.
Conspiracy theorists believe that Obama is
a Muslim extremist that hates America and
wants to destroy it by any means possible.
However it cannot be done by force so the
surely the fastest way to see America fall
would be to affect it financially.
The US is currently in debt to the tune of
$17.2 trillion.
During Obama's presidency campaign he promised
to cut America's deficit by half.
But he in fact increased the nation's deficit
by a staggering $6.7 trillion.
To put that in perspective during the 8 year
term of George W. Bush's presidency he increased
the deficit by $4.9 trillion.
This of course has led to widespread conspiracies
suggesting that Obama secretly has malicious
intentions towards the US.
If you've had the swine flu jab you may already
be a victim of a rather disturbing theory.
Conspiracy theorists believe that the swine
flu and bird flu jabs and other vaccines contain
microscopic computer chips invisible to the
naked eye.
That have been injected into the population
en masse without them knowing.
Theorists believe these nano chips will be
used to track and even control the entire
population.
Some believe it has links to the New World
Order, and when the time comes for a mass
population cull people who carry the nano
chip will be able to be terminated at the
flick of a switch.
Theorists back up such theories with evidence
such as these thousands of plastic coffins
being stored in a field in Georgia, which
could be used to dispose of bodies in a mass
cull.
Although others say they are simply grave
liners, designed to protect real coffins from
the harsh elements.
One of the most outlandish modern conspiracies
surrounds the Chelyabinsk Meteor that exploded
over Russia on the 15th February 2013.
During midmorning a flash of light appeared
in the sky over the Russian town causing a
colossal shockwave that shook the surrounding
area, shattered hundreds of windows and injured
1,100 people.
The most plausible explanation is that a meteor
entered the Earth's atmosphere and exploded
in the sky.
But the creative minds of conspiracy theorists
all over the world came up with another scenario.
That the the meteor was actually a manifestation
from the world's most advanced video game.
The largest fragment found from the meteorite
could easily fit into a human hand.
Conspiracy theorists maintain that such a
large object would not have been so thoroughly
vaporised as it seemed to have been.
The absence of large fragments supports their
theory that an experimental video game developer
delving into the possibilities of virtual
reality, cracked the ultimate computer code
and allowed a video game experience to manifest
itself in reality.
Could the United States be in cahoots with
North Korea?
That's what some theorists believe.
The relationship between the United States
and North Korea is at all time low.
But some people think it's all just a coverup
and the two countries are actually close allies
working together.
There are only really three pieces of evidence
to back up these claims, firstly American
basketball player Dennis Rodman bizarrely
met with Kim Jong-un in North Korea and publicly
vowed eternal friendship with the North Korean
leader.
The second piece of evidence is simply that
North Korea would have a pathetic chance if
it were to launch a war against the most technologically
advanced military in history, so becoming
enemies with them doesn't seem like a very
wise idea.
And finally in 2012 the United States sent
a 240 thousand tonne shipment of food to North
Korea, despite relations between the two countries
already being dire.
Which begs the question why would they do
this if they're not allies?